52 this represents 52.1 final votes
I therefore declare I'm the Yusuf Julie
elected as the Scottish national party
leader
it's never easy starting a new job I
will be a first Minister for all of
Scotland that I will work every minute
of every day to earn and to re-air your
respect and your trust Hamza Yousaf has
got to do it though knowing he's
following in the footsteps of a hugely
successful first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon was a formidable Communicator
she carved out a powerful Public Image
for herself winning elections overseeing
political dominance for the SMP in
Scotland
and as if all that isn't daunting enough
hamster Yousaf also needs to unify the
party after a rather bruising leadership
battle and it wasn't a great look for
the SMP Dirty Laundry was aired the
subject of gay marriage was questioned
and it emerged SMP members have deserted
the party in the tens of thousands we
are no longer team Hamza or team Ash or
team Kate we are one team and we will be
the team we will be the generation that
delivers Independence for Scotland
where there are divisions to heal we
must do so quickly because we have a job
to do so what does all this mean for
Scottish independence with Hamza Yousaf
as first Minister I'm Sally Lockwood and
this is the Sky News Daily
now we're recording this podcast shortly
after the big reveal at murrayfield
Stadium when Hamza Yousaf was announced
as the winner this is probably the least
shocking result uh in this contest our
Scottish correspondent Connor Gillis was
just a few feet away from the podium and
joins me now from the road as he makes
his way from murrayfield back to
Hollywood Hamza Yusuf was seen as the
favorite candidate from the outset he's
been at the helm of government for
almost a decade was recently serving as
Scotland's Health secretary in charge of
the devolved NHS and he is a close Ally
of Nicolas sturgeon and the outgoing
team at the top of government so this
win is a big victory for the SMP
establishment but I think it's far from
surprising now he's seen as the
continuity candidate isn't he Connor and
you know he was certainly ahead in the
polls among SNP members but not among
wider public hate Forbes was the more
popular candidate so so what do you
think this means for him Hamza Yusuf
spent his entire
campaign this five-week campaign
pivoting his conversation directly to
the 70 000 SMP members who did have a
vote in this ballot and that was not the
approach that his rival Kate Forbes took
she
thought it was important that if the SNP
is to achieve that mission that goal of
Independence then she needed to bring
the public on site and convince those
who voted no in 2014 bring them back on
site and build that case for
Independence Hamza Yusuf took a very
different approach the polls were
telling us a story that he was the most
popular out of all three candidates when
it came to those internal members
however between him and Kate Forbes he
was the least favorable candidate
between those uh branding him the most
weak incompetent and untrustworthy and
that's something that I put directly to
him in that q a that happened in those
immediate moments after he became the
SNP leader I'm delighted to have been
part of that election winning machine
and being part of government for 10 and
a half years but on top of that of
course I'm delighted that when I've
stood for an election I've been elected
and re-elected with a big majority from
the people of Glasgow politics I'd like
to thank and putting their trust in me
over the years but what I'll make sure I
do is I govern and govern what in the
interest of the people of Scotland but
also we win the trust of the people of
Scotland when we govern uh and we
aligned with their priorities their
priorities have to be our priorities and
of course they will look to us for
delivery and I will do my best to
deliver what is their priorities and at
the moment I don't have to tell anybody
in this room that people are suffering
from a cost of living crisis that'll be
my first and immediate priority
one of the most immediate challenges now
is how he transforms his fortunes into
talking to the wider public and creating
a message that will continue to build on
the snp's election winning fortunes of
the last 20 years or so now Conor I was
really interested by the story that
emerged showing you know SMP members
have deserted the party in droves
and the s p initially tried to deny the
story when it was broken the spin Doctor
Murray foot called the story drivel then
resigned when it emerged it was true
what's going on when this row erupted
just during the course of the campaign
this suggestion that the SNP was not
being transparent with its numbers it
had been thought it had around 100 000
members and the Sunday meal here in
Scotland the newspaper
said that it had obtained information
that it had drastically lost numbers
down to around seventy thousand now at
that point uh the s p and the hierarchy
within headquarters here in Edinburgh
denied that report to modifoot as you
say the chief spin doctor was sent out
to rubbish that piece of Journalism
and the party came under sustained
pressure to publish its true figures and
when it eventually you turned and did
reveal those figures I lost tens of
thousands in the space of just 18 months
that led to all sorts of rows within the
senior members of the SMP and is there
any idea or any Clarity yet Connor as to
why so many members have left the
Scottish national party the party said
the reasons for the huge drop-in
membership numbers I'll also have a
third of their members
could be in part largely in part down to
the cost of living crisis and people not
having the money the cash to to spend on
those membership fees at a time when
household budgets are already stretched
to a Breaking Point critics of the party
would suggest that they Almighty Route
Around gender reforms that piece of
legislation controversial piece of
legislation here in Scotland to make it
easier to change your gender allowing 16
and 17 year olds the option to change
their gender without any doctor
interfering at any point that
created a lot of unease among certain
wings of the party just on the agenda
recognition Bill Connor of course it was
passed in Hollywood blocked in
Westminster what happens now it Hamza
Yusuf was in support of that bill wasn't
he he was around the cabinet table when
that decision was being made and Hamza
Yusuf is putting himself on a
constitutional Clash on day one already
with the UK government who are blocking
this legislation because they say it is
having a negative impact or could have a
negative impact on UK wide equality laws
Hamza Yusuf has said that he will fight
this in court because it's important
that Devolution is respected
let's take a closer look now at what the
new SMP leader means for the future of
the party and just what damage was done
by the rather brutal leadership contest
I think there will be a lot of huge size
of relief among the politicians in the
party not least Nicholas sturgeon
they're going first Minister Shana
Craven is a columnist at the national
the newspaper which backs Scottish
independence
it was widely accepted that Hamza Yusuf
was her preferred winner of this race
yes a lot less controversy about sort of
bringing the party back together
especially um at Hollywood and forming a
government and then choosing a cabinet
Hamza Youssef was the most popular
candidate according to the polls within
the SMP but but not within the wider
Scottish public Cape Forbes was ahead in
those polls
how do you think he's going to get on is
he going to be able to cut through well
he's very well known to the Scottish
public but he has had some some pretty
challenging briefs you know he was the
Justice secretary he presided over the
hate crime bill which has proved very
controversial and has actually yet to be
implemented and then he took over the
job of Health secretary during the cover
pandemic so that was never going to be
easy he was always going to be under
pressure there but you know he would
Point himself to the fact that the the
figures on the Health Service in terms
of a e Etc are better than England and
that's not the Benchmark that Scotland
wishes to set itself against but it
still is a pretty strong retort to
people who suggest that he's failed you
know as health secretary I'm not saying
that it's an easier job being first
Minister than it is being Health
secretary but I don't think it'd be too
sad to see that job oh Shona let's just
go over what Kate Forbes said about
Hamza Yusuf she was very critical of his
record uh in government generally
claiming the trains were never on time
when he was the transport secretary that
the police were at breaking point when
he was Justice secretary and of course
now the NHS has had many crises not
least the longest ever waiting lists uh
while he was at the helm on the health
brief
does she have a point
well I think there was Steve for all X
all extremely uh over the top I mean
obviously the trains were sometimes on
time and I think mostly on time although
I'm sure it often didn't feel like that
to some commuters and overall crime fell
now can can a Justice secretary
necessarily take credit for that perhaps
not it's a kind of ongoing Trend and
obviously if we're creating new crimes
then you may expect a crime to go up and
I think with the NHS you really have a
very strong argument that you are are
doing that with one hand tie behind your
back in terms of not having influence
over uh immigration policy
um in terms of obviously budgetary
restrictions which apply across all
Scottish government areas and of course
the backdrop of the pandemic comes the
use of this constantly been apologizing
for uh the state of things
um but you know as an sap politician he
would be the first to acknowledge that
there's a lot of factors the impact on
that one of which of course is things
like uh income tax and retaining
well-paid doctors in Scotland and I
wonder if you might have a little bit of
a conflict there with some of the things
he said about progressive taxation and
there's a sort of brutal reality of how
to run a country post-brexit within the
the current Evolution settlement
let's move on now to the debate over gay
marriage that we heard uh cropping up
during this contest
has the perception that Scotland is
super Progressive with its gender
recognition Bill been undone in this
leadership contest with all this
discussion about views on gay marriage
something that for many was was put to
bed in 2014 and is in his videos a very
straightforward issue to most voters it
was put to bed in 2014
visit and reopen and change anything in
regard to that and it's interesting that
the sort of where you feel in the
question a lot of people in Scotland do
not regard the gender recognition Reform
Bill as Progressive at all because they
see the ways in which it can impact
negatively on the rates of women and
girls but also more broadly some of the
discourse about equality and who's
Progressive and who's backwards
there's a lot to get into with that what
does this outcome Hamza Youssef now
winning mean for Independence does it
feel closer or further away in your
opinion in a post sturgeon era so
there's a question of whether hums are
used of can rally the troops or indeed
delegate rallying of the troops to
someone else successfully so that
everyone who currently supports their
dependents which includes green voters
which includes non-voters which includes
people who are in Alexander's Alba party
can uh Hamza Yusuf ensure that the
people who support Independence now will
continue to support it will continue to
have faith that there will be an
opportunity to have another vote on
Independence but also can he convert
undecided or current law voting people
to the cause I think the latter will be
much trickier the former because he's
obviously the preferred candidate of the
greens he can probably keep them on site
although the greens have been making a
lot of quite fighting talk about how
tough they'll be about whether they will
continue to support the SMP making
various demands there's a central
conflict at the heart of what homes are
used has been trying to do he's been
trying to argue that Scotland can be a
better place under his leadership but
obviously in order to argue for
Independence you have to keep reminding
people of the limits to what you can do
as a default Administration so that's
constantly a problem it wouldn't
necessarily play well to say well
anything that's going well it's all my
responsibility and anything that's going
badly it's the limits of devolution even
if that's true people don't necessarily
like to hear what they consider to be
excuses and a lot of what all the
candidates promised during the
leadership campaign I'm not convinced
they can deliver under the current
constitutional setup do you think the
smps focus on Independence has come at a
cost to other domestic issues such as
you know we've seen the attainment Gap
in schools that that hasn't been closed
Scotland's got a shameful record on drug
related deaths problems in the NHS do
you think we're going to see Hamza Yusuf
focus more on these domestic issues
the short term definitely as part of his
stated aim of boosting support for
Independence I've noticed when he's
asked about education he focuses very
much on the links between poor
attainment and poverty so um and
obviously everyone agrees children can't
be hungry at school breakfast clubs are
a good thing making sure that children
can concentrate but it's not just about
money so I think he needs to get away
from just talking about attainment um as
being inextricably linked to you know a
child being poor and a child being
hungry and and broaden that out a little
bit we can't talk about Hamza yusuf's
Victory Shona without talking about the
historic sense of this moment that he's
the first Muslim to lead a major UK
party the first Asian to take control of
a devolved Administration and he touched
on this in his acceptance speech
speaking of his grandparents who arrived
in Scotland from Punjab unfortunately
they're no longer alive to see this
thing but I'm forever forever thankful
that my grandparents made the trip from
Punjab to Scotland over 60 years ago as
immigrants to this country who knew
barely a word of English they could not
have imagined and their wildest dreams
that their grandson would one day be on
the cusp of being the next first
minister of Scotland it's quite a story
he has talked about how his parents
would have much rather in a very Asian
stereotypical way him become a doctor or
a dentist or an accountant or something
like that and so while some people are a
bit cynical about what they term a
career politician you know somebody who
they sort of perceived to be I don't
know in some way disingenuous there is
also you know he does also have a real
background in charitable volunteering
and getting involved and things like
that and I think what we've seen in
Hamza Yusuf as he's evolved as a
politician is that he's perhaps a little
less hot-headed than he was he's very
passionate as he'll say about equalities
issues not least as a minority an ethnic
minority and and religious minority
is now following in the footsteps of
political Giants with Nicholas sturgeon
and Alex salmond
how tough do you think that's going to
be for him it will be tough I think
I think can take the time to to to sort
of set out his stall and I think even in
the leadership campaign you could see
him adjusting his policies and adjusting
his message in response to what was
going down well or going down badly and
I don't think there's necessarily
anything hugely wrong with that so I
think he'll continue to listen to his
own members especially given how close
the vote was and also to The Wider
public because you know there's no point
just trying to plow on with the path
that you think is best if you don't
think it's going to continue the
Electoral success that was achieved
under the previous leaders let's bring
Connor back to see what he thinks lies
ahead now in terms of Hamza yusuf's
priorities
the big question is how will he tackle
Independence because we know that Nicola
sturgeon failed to deliver the snp's
central Mission it's hard to see exactly
how that will happen anytime soon
because the polls are certainly not
shifting in that direction if Hamza
Youssef wanted to hold an indie ref 2
something that Nico sturgeon didn't
succeed in doing but to have another
Independence referendum in Scotland what
would he need in order for that to
happen I don't want to bore you with all
the ins and outs of the different acts
and legislation but the Scotland act
says the way that it's set up at the
moment and the way that Hollywood is set
up is that the UK and Scottish
government needs to come to an agreement
so that was called the Edinburgh
agreement back in 2014 it's when the
then Prime Minister David Cameron agreed
that the polls were looking like there
should be a referendum at that point
both sides agreed and that's what
happened and September of 2014 what's
changed since then is we've had a raft
of prime ministers at Westminster who
have said now is not the time to rerun
that question as it stands Hollywood
does not have the powers to hold a
second Independence referendum to the
gold standard uh phrase that also phrase
actually that's always used when we're
comparing 2014 so that will not happen
anytime soon Rishi sunak has made it
clear that he will not be shifting his
position on that so it leaves it up
times the use of to determine whether he
wants to use
the next general election or elections
further into the future
um to try and secure Independence I know
how long it takes to get from
murrayfield to Hollywood so I'm sure
you're pretty much back there by now
thank you so much for joining us you
didn't make up the timing we're
literally pulling up that was great
timing so yeah Flawless timing
my thanks to Connor Gillis and Shona
Craven and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Annie Joyce
our editor is Philly Beaumont